Zahlreiche wissenschaftler und unternehmer warnt vor künstlicher intelligenz
kurz ki allen voran ihren masken stephen hawking ihre maske waren sogar vor dem schreckensszenario
Marodierender und menschen mordender roboter die hacker community steht jetzt in den startlöchern um sich
im notfall
Gegen einen solchen angriff zu wehren welche risiken uns demnächst rohn ob diese
befürchtungen den anfang vom ende der menschheit bedeuten könnten und wie die hacker gemeinschaft
Gegen kämpfen will jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Künstliche intelligenz ki die uns schon bald haushoch überlegen ist sie uns eventuell
kontrolliert manipuliert und sogar regiert das war wohl mit das top-thema auf dem 34
chaos communication congress
Ende dezember in leipzig hacker aus aller welt und wissenschaftler und journalisten und interessierte haben sich hier getroffen
um über
Selbstlernende maschinen zu beraten und bei einem punkt sind sich wohl alle einig ki
Und deren unter bereiche wie das die learning oder maschinen learning durchziehen schon jetzt fast alle
bereiche unseres lebens wir haben ja
eh schon öfter mal das stichwort die burning gehabt mit hilfe einer riesigen menge an daten und
beispielen bringen sich maschinen selbst bei was zu tun ist eine künstliche intelligenz also die allmächtig ist in der
medizintechnik dem militär und auch der automobilentwicklung ist genau das grab der
Heiße shit und nicht nur auf dem hacker kongress in leipzig ist die zunehmende skepsis und in gewisser
weise auch furcht vor einer übermächtigen ki ein zentrales thema sondern auch in anderen bereichen
Der wirtschaft der politik und der forschung die große frage die über allem steht
Wird die ki uns irgendwann mehr schaden als nutzen wird sie uns menschen bald
Haushoch
überlegen sein wird sie vielleicht sogar zur größten gefahr der menschheit tatsächlich
vorstellbar sagt beispielsweise der britische science fiction autor charles stroß
Anlässlich des hacker treffen sind leipzig er warnt vor systemen die darauf trainiert werden propaganda. Im netz
beispielsweise von staatlicher seite aus machine learning
basierte systeme könnten zu dem video oder audio material fälschen oder aber auch darauf abziehen
internet user durch gezielte reize so zu manipulieren dass sie
Psychisch kaum mehr in der lage sind von der virtuellen welt in die reale welt
zu wechseln seine worte bevor eine ki
zu solchen dingen in der lage ist müssen wir dringend strategien
Entwickeln damit sie uns damit nicht über den kopf wächst eine eindringliche warnung doch angenommen
Dies gelingt uns nicht wäre das dann der anfang vom ende der menschheit so jedenfalls
Definiert es marc uwe kling der autor der känguru chroniken in seiner
Zukunft satire auf dem leipziger hacker kongress in seiner vision sind alle wirklich alle bereiche des lebens
von algorithmen optimiert beziehungen arbeit und die freizeit doch das problem die menschen
gleichen sich immer mehr den maschinen an und die maschinen werden tatsächlich menschlicher drohnen die flugangst haben oder
Kampfroboter die psychisch vom krieg mitgenommen sind das ist natürlich in erster linie
Satirisch gemeint allerdings durchaus auch als warnung zu verstehen nicht wenige
Expertinnen weltweit weisen immer wieder auf die gefahren und nachteile der ki
Hin und auch deutsche forscher in sind darunter zb der ki forscher
henrik meyer und seine kollegin karin ullrich auf dem leipziger kongress erinnerten sie noch einmal ein
katastrophaler fans von maschinen learning system die bereits in der vergangenheit gezeigt hätten dass sie zitat eine art geldwäsche für vorurteile
sein können in den usa gibt es beispielsweise software die einschätzt wie hoch das risiko ist dass strafgefangene rückfällig werden und jetzt
Haltet euch fest also wir hatten ja schon darüber berichtet werden damals ich gesehen hat die ki
hatte ausgehend von den trainingsdaten die hautfarbe eines menschen als entscheidendes merkmal dafür
identifiziert was sie dabei nicht wissen konnte der grund dafür ist die voreingenommenheit der polizei und die sozialen bedingungen ein
unfassbares beispiel für schlimme diskriminierung gehen natürlich folglich wenn man konsequenzen mit sich bringen kann als ein weiteres beispiel nennt das deutsche
forschungsteam den algorithmus von facebook der in der letzten konsequenz
auswirkungen darauf haben kann wie die user die welt sehen denn der newsfeed werde zwar in die
wer jedoch nicht nach nachvollziehbaren
Maßgaben sortieren so lautet die große über alles stehende frage wie kann, so etwas kontrolliert und verhindert werden markus beckedahl der den blog
Netzpolitik.org gegründet hat zitat wir brauchen regularien um zu schauen wie kriegen wir eine
Nachvollziehbarkeit und eine demokratische kontrolle von dem hin wie algorithmen eingesetzt werden
Konkret nennt er kartellämter und datenschutz behörden die den umgang mit den algorithmen nicht nur bei facebook sondern auch in anderen bereichen der gesellschaft
kontrollieren könnten diese kontrolle institutionen sollten dann notfalls auch geschäftsgeheimnisse
einsehen dürfen eine andere forderung
Um gegen eine allmähliche ki
Zu kämpfen kommt von der amerikanerin catherine jamal sie ruft zur praktischen gegenwehr auf das stichwort lautet
etwa
serienmaschinen learning eine kategorie der
computersicherheit die man böse auch als
spielverderber bezeichnen könnte denn hierbei geht es darum
Künstliche neuronale netze zu wärmeren zu täuschen und auszutricksen auf forscher innen die in ihrem unternehmen
Eigentlich daran arbeiten die weiter zu entwickeln probieren sich daraus einfach um zu sehen was möglich ist und die erfolge
künstliche intelligenzen auszutricksen er waren in der vergangenheit
überraschend erfolgreich konkret funktioniert das mit speziell manipulierten
trainingsdaten oder inputs die die ki dann dazu bringt falsche ergebnisse zu liefern ein beispiel
Wäre ein selbst fahrendes auto das tatsächlich von manipulierten
straßenschildern fehlgeleitet wird die
forschern katrin jamal hat selbst solch ein experiment gestartet und ein foto von ihrer person, so
verändert ihr ziel die gesichtserkennung von facebook sollte annehmen sie sei eine katze
Hundertprozentig geklappt hat das nicht allerdings wurde da mal nicht mehr vorgeschlagen sich selbst auf dem bild mit ihrem namen
Zu markieren das bedeutet also dass sich das programm selbst nicht mehr sicher war ob es sich
um jamal oder überhaupt
Um das einer menschlichen person handelt möglich gemacht wird dass tatsächlich von einer menge an open source
werkzeugen und genau die soll die hacker community die damals aufruf zufolge nutzen und zwar für
Gute zwecke auch der chaos computer club ccc ist in die debatte. Um dieses problemfeld
sensibilisiert linus neumann einer der sprecher warnt davor dass die
Ungleichheiten unserer gesellschaft weiter vertieft werden er bezieht sich damit auf dem fakt dass ki
hauptsächlich von gewinnorientierten unternehmen
entwickelt und angewendet wird wo bleiben dabei die interessen der gesellschaft, hinsichtlich
Freiheit und gleichheit man wolle als cc c die ki
Und ihre bereiche keineswegs verteufeln dennoch fordert auch, er kontroll
Kriterien denn nur so könnten die negativen konsequenzen der ki zu verhindern sein und auch der ccc wird ihr handeln
Notfalls auch in notwehr ob sie was damit. Gemeint ist der ccc als untergrundarmee
gegen ki auf jeden fall können sich die widerstandskämpfer in so einem fall auf artikel 20 absatz 4
Im grundgesetz stützen zitat gegen jeden der es unternimmt diese ordnung also unsere grundordnung
zu beseitigen haben alle deutschen das recht zum widerstand wenn andere abhilfe nicht möglich ist
Hoffen wir dass es nicht so weit kommt wie groß die gefahr ist dass erfahrt ihr immer wieder in videos hier
Zum thema ki wenn der kanzler von verpassen wollen und auch
Zu allen anderen themen dann wird man hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht dem
Genau auf die glocke wirklich nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert ansonsten greift nämlich der algorithmus ein ja und hier geht
es weiter mit dafür draufklicken bedroht künstliche intelligenz die menschheit
ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran